Amazon YouTube and Netflix have three
different models they do original
content but they do it in a different
way in in Netflix this case most of
their content is not original it only
roughly two percent of their budget is
originals but they're increasingly
spending more money
house of cards they made a hundred
million dollar commitment for two
seasons but now they've just signed to
go to a third season of that and they've
got some other original programs like
orange is the new black and and and some
others what Amazon is done is the
different model there is they basically
said if you spend seventy nine dollars a
year to get free delivery of any Amazon
product we will throw in free video so
you can watch movies or some of the
original Gary Trudeau series they've
just done some of the originals like
that that you can do but essentially
it's you're not an individual subscriber
at Netflix you're paying eight dollars
you know a month to be a Netflix
subscriber and Amazon you're you're
paying the $79 for delivery and we don't
know and they don't tell you how many of
them are watching video Amazon is very
secretive about its numbers and but in a
way what they're doing is what they did
with the Kindle or with books they
subsidized they give things at a low
price to you in order to get you into
their store to buy other things and
they've been very successful with that
what YouTube does still another model
they moved away from user-generated
content but increasingly they're trying
to produce more professional content it
tends to be of shorter form you know
quicker shows etc but they are buying
product as is Verizon and AT&T and and
some others so there's a there's a lot
of competition in in that space and
increasingly I mean Reed Hastings if
Netflix predicts that within just a
couple of years half of a television
that we watch will be delivered over the
Internet
that's a big deal because it means that
you
and ooh binge-watching you can know more
about your customers and you can
schedule for yourself then one of the
questions will be and this is a big
question
if I control my television set for the
digital video I'm watching and be it
through my cable box or some other form
I can skip ads what happens to to
advertising-supported cable networks and
particularly broadcast networks that are
relying on advertising that's a huge
question because the people who are
watching Netflix and the kids who are
watching YouTube and or the people
watching Amazon they're they've become
accustomed to not having to watch ads
and in fact half the people who have a
cable box you know with with a PVR
ability to tape shows are skipping the
ads so what happens to advertising
supported television and if advertising
supported television in trouble who's
going to pay for or five million dollars
in episode for some quality drama like
say The Good Wife on CBS big issues out
there
you